No
there's so many artists out there all
over the world that are making art
really I know this sounds idealistic
really because they're artists and they
just have to make things and they come
through the art schools or they don't go
to art schools and maybe they're
influenced by a trend or a theory maybe
they even want to make money from art
but they're making art I've never really
met that many people that make art just
to make money there's so many other ways
to make money it's the same with
investing in the end you hear about
these people that want to make money
from investing you can make so much more
money investing the traditional ways
than you can from investing in art that
there's certain a certain mythology
about that even though yes of course
some people have made money from Bernard